[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 culture nous sommes devant le
musée fournaise à chatou est cette
émission spéciale sera en grande partie
consacrée au centenaire renoir le 3
décembre 2019 ou commémorera les 100 ans
de la disparition du célèbre artiste
peintre plus de détails dans le sommaire
hommage jusqu'à la fin de l'année dans
les yvelines à l'un des plus célèbres
peintres français pierre auguste renoir
a vécu plusieurs années dans le
département et a réalisé plusieurs
oeuvres majeures comme la grenouillère à
croissy sur seine où le déjeuner des
canotiers à chatou le musée fournissent
propose d'ailleurs un véritable parcours
spectacle immersion dans la vie de
l'artiste avec nos invités
et puis dans ce numéro nous vous
présenterons également une sélection de
quatre idées de sorties afin compte en
yvelines musique théâtre humour il y en
aura pour tous les goûts
nous sommes au musée fournaise à chatou
un lieu est très cher à renoir comme
vous allez le découvrir dans quelques
minutes
mais avant je vous propose de découvrir
un petit sujet pour mieux connaître
l'artiste notamment ses liens si
particulier avec les départements des
yvelines
né à limoges le 25 février 1841 pierre
auguste renoir débute sa vie artistique
à 14 ans à paris il entre ensuite à
l'école des beaux-arts et devient membre
à part entière du groupe impressionniste
ses parents déménagent ensuite dans les
yvelines le département s'appelait à
l'époque seine et oise
ils vivent notamment rue de voisins à
louveciennes cesson nie toute la vallée
de la seine a été pour lui un vrai lieu
de création d'imagination et puis je
dirais de vécu dans sa bougival la
grenouillère à croissy sur seine ou
encore le célèbre déjeuner des canotiers
à chatou les paysages de la vallée de la
seine ont inspiré l'artiste renoir qui à
son tour a inspiré le département des
yvelines à l'occasion du centenaire de
sa disparition
nous sommes en train de développer sur
la scène toute une énergie de
déploiement touristique puisque nous
avons un potentiel véritablement accès
aujourd'hui sur ''le les grands peintres
impressionnistes pierre auguste renoir
s'étend le 3 décembre 1919 à cagnes sur
mer
laissant derrière lui plus de 4000
tableau michel grelier bon jour pour
jour vous êtes adjointe au maire de
château en charge de la culture vous
êtes notamment occupé de coordonner les
différentes manifestations pour le
centenaire de renard on en parlera bien
sûr dans cette émission à vos côtés à
carole un bonjour un plongeur vous êtes
adjointe au conservateur du musée
fournaise à chatou alors on l'a vu en
bien sûr dans ce sujet pierre auguste
renoir alors était né à limoges il
c'était un canular
et pourtant il était très attaché au
département des yvelines notamment à
château où il a vécu il me semble prêt
de près de 15 ans il me semble en
pourquoi justement cet attachement au
département des yvelines
c'est un cadre naturel qui qui plaisait
beaucoup en fait à ces artistes qui ont
beaucoup pas en plein air monnet 6
lehman et berthe morisot tous aussi
avait soigné un appartement une maison
un pied-à-terre dans les environs aussi
donc c'était l'endroit idéal pour eux
pour se retrouver entre amis et
poursuivre la recherche de peinture et
un michel grillé c'était j'ai envie de
dire une évidence que la ville de chatou
rendent hommage à renoir pour pour ce
centenaire
ob plus qu'une évidence c'était une
certitude en tout cas c'est vrai que
chatou que ça d'orgueil d'avoir renoir à
shattuck avec la maison fournaise le diu
nous sommes actuellement et le
restaurant fournaise il se devait de
faire quelque chose de beau
deux reconnus et c'est vrai qu'avec
l'aide du département de la région on a
vraiment été suivies et des mécènes et
sponsors pour faire de cet événement
quelque chose qui rayonne au delà de
chatou donc aller qu'on y soit alors on
se trouve justement dans la dernière
salle 1 du musée font naître qui a été
entièrement repensé qui a été
transformée justement à l'occasion du
centenaire vous proposer un parcours
spectacle 1 on va le voir bien sûr dans
quelques instants
mais juste avant quelques mots sur ce
lieu le restaurant fournet c'était une
guinguette ans et ça à l'époque un oui
c'est ça en fait d'assez l'une des
dernière guerres gâte conserver sur les
bords de seine il en reste sur les bords
de marne et dans cette région lanaudoise
de l'île de france c'est l'une des
dernières qui reste conservé aujourd'hui
à la garder en plus un petit peu sa
vocation d'origine puisque même si c'est
plus exactement une guinguette c'est
resté un restaurant une partie du
bâtiment a été consacrée au musée et à
l'époque au 19e siècle dans la seconde
moitié du 19e siècle jusqu'au début du
20e
c'était vraiment le lieu de rendez-vous
du tout paris il y avait évidemment des
personnes issues des milieux populaires
des personnes issues de la bourgeoisie
même parfois de l'a22 de la noblesse
aussi qui venait ici pour respirer un
peu un air de liberté qui était très
important pour la l'époque puisque c'est
ici aussi qui a été peint notamment le
célèbre déjeuner des canotiers on va le
voir d'ailleurs dans dans ce sujet
puisqu'on va voir quelques images de
cette expérience immersive que vous
proposez justement aux visiteurs
[Musique]
accueilli par le maître des lieux les
visiteurs sont instantanément transporté
au milieu du 19e siècle
à cette époque la maison fournaise est
le lieu de prédilection des peintres
impressionnistes
à l'occasion du centenaire de la mort
d'auguste renoir le musée propose une
expérience immersive
comme il est extrêmement difficile de
pouvoir présenter des tableaux de renoir
qui sont conservés aux journées dans le
monde entier
l'idée était de raconter son histoire
ici à chatou lorsqu'il avait deux autour
d'une trentaine d'années et je sais ce
qu'il pèse déjeuner des canotiers
auguste renoir a passé une douzaine
d'années à chatou et c'est ici même sur
l'île des impressionnistes qu'il a peint
le célèbre tableau des écrans numériques
des tablettes ou des casques de réalité
virtuelle permettent d'entrer au coeur
de la peinture de l'artiste
dès l'entrée on propose au visiteur via
un écran tactile de s'amuser entre
guillemets avec les tableaux de renoir
et les recomposer donc on choisit un
tableau et on a différents objets qu'on
va finir pouvoir insérer dans le tableau
les modifier les agrandir les tournées
18 mois de travaux ont été nécessaires
pour imaginer cette expérience numérique
qui se veut aussi ludique
qu'enrichissante
[Musique]
alors michel grillé pour ce géant veut
dire nouveau musée pourquoi avoir fait
ce choix du numérique puisque le
numérique est vraiment comme on vient de
le voir bien présent justement dans ce
parcours
et bien alors il ya deux raisons une
première raison c'est que un petit musée
municipal ne peut pas accueillir les
oeuvres qui sont disséminés dans le
monde entier notamment aux états unis en
termes d'assurance de coûts de transport
énormément de choses et qu' il fallait
donner un nouvel élan à ce musée faire
venir une population plus jeune parce
que c'est vrai c'est toujours et barbe
hâtive quand on est jeune venir leur
amusé on a toujours l'impression de
s'ennuyer et on a saisi cette
opportunité du 100e anniversaire la mort
de renoir pour changer complètement
notre vision de ce musée est alors carol
allain qui a contribué qui a collaboré
finalement à ce musée en fait
alors pour ce parcours spectacle en fait
c'est un gars loyers qui a été à
l'origine du projet en galloyer qu'est
le conservateur revient voir justement
dans le sujet là du musée fournaise
exactement elle a été second départ tout
un petit comité on va dire qu'on
appelait comité renoir par la suite nous
avons fait appel à un scénographe
metteur en scène qui est venu avec ses
équipes son réseau de techniciens de
menuisier de tapissière il y avait
différents corps de métiers qui ont été
sollicités pour mettre en place ce
parcours bien vous lisiez cette nouvelle
expérience dont qui a été réalisé dans
le cadre du centenaire la ville de
château a mis en place également
d'autres manifestations est ce que vous
pouvez nous donner quelques temps fort
justement qui attendent le public
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
donc la prochaine c'est le 14 novembre
les deux renoir génie et sensibilité
avec rené max critique de cinéma donc
c'est le 14 novembre
renoir dans la vie des enfants à la
médiathèque exposition c'est simple
étape et en descente du 3 au 21 10 ans
rencontre signature avec jacques renoir
dans la médiathèque aussi
voilà l'arrière petit fils en douala
d'auguste renoir et des auteurs la bande
dessinée donc on a vraiment des têtes d
affiche de belles signatures et tout ça
dans disséminés dans tout dans toute la
ville et puis bhl de nombreux artistes
peintres sculpteurs qui ont participé
aussi tout au long de cette année il ya
plusieurs villes aussi un client
collaborait à 3,6 port-marly surtout
croatie qui est limitrophe avec mu la
grenouillère et voilà et bien justement
on va justement prendre la direction a
dû musée de la grenouillère qui propose
jusqu'au 31 décembre une nouvelle
exposition intitulée 1869 renoir à la
grenouillère une année magnifique lieu
de mémoire sur la fameuse guinguette du
bord de seine durant la belle époque la
grenouillère a été transformée en musée
en 1990 est géré par une association de
passionnés c'est tout naturellement
qu'une exposition est consacrée jusqu'à
la fin de l'année au célèbre peintre
impressionniste pierre auguste renoir en
1869 les artistes peintre monet et
renoir sont venus peindre la
grenouillère célèbre à cette époque
auprès des parisiens et de la société
des environs et qui venait s'amuser
monet a peint trois tableaux et renoir
en a peint trois également la
grenouillère qui attire ce même été 1869
l'empereur napoléon iii sa femme jenny
et leur fils mannequin reproductions de
tableaux coupures de journaux la plupart
des objets exposés appartiennent à
l'association les amis de la
grenouillère
la pièce centrale de l'exposition met en
avant le travail de renoir à croissy sur
seine lors de sa première visite en 1869
mais aussi en 1911 année durant laquelle
il a peint une actrice et chanteuse de
l'époque
amélie est elle là a peintes dans son
jardin de la villa qu'elle possédait
accroît civile là-haut fall ce tableau
que vous voyez ici est détenue par la
fondation barnes à philadelphie à partir
des archives détenu par kroll à la
commune de croatie nous avons fait une
vitrine montrant des photos de l'actrice
dans ses costumes de scène
et puis dans les publicités qu'elle a
tourné dans la dernière salle l'univers
de la guinguette a été recréé avec des
instruments de musique
cette plongée dans l'ambiance du siècle
dernier est visible jusqu'à la fin de
l'année les mercredis et dimanches après
midi alors bien sûr un le centenaire
renoir dans les yvelines c'est à
découvrir jusqu'à la fin de l'année
alors michel rien on a oublié aussi de
paris d'un d'un rang des fins d'un
rendez vous ici on peut dire ça date un
mook avec un mook qui est fait par le
centre d'études et histoire de l'art
donc sur renoir et ce tout au long de
l'année n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire à
c est bien sûr on va se retrouver toutes
les informations sur sur un site
internet le site internet de la ville de
chatou les la formation passe bien et
carol allain le musée fournaise qui est
ouvert tous les jours de la semaine où
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner les
informations pratiques pour venir
découvrir ou redécouvrir même ce
parcours spectacle consacré à un noir
alors oui en fait on est ouvert
quasiment sept jours sur sept on est
ouvert pour le grand public du mercredi
au dimanche et en fait les lundis et les
mardis on accueille les groupes
scolaires centres de loisirs ou quelques
groupes aussi un adulte sur réservation
lorsque c'est possible et on est ouvert
quasiment toute l'année on va juste
avoir une petite fermeture au moment des
fêtes de noël mais voilà le parcours
spectacle devrait se prolonger aussi en
2020 merci en tout cas toutes les deux
nous avoir permis de mieux connaître
pierre auguste renoir et juste avant de
se quitter je vous propose d'aller faire
un tour du côté de san quentin en
yvelines avec ses quatre idées de sortie
le 12 novembre le théâtre alphonse
daudet à coignières accueil monsieur
fraize l'humoriste s'est fait notamment
connaître dans l'émission on n'demande
qu'à en rire
le 15 novembre andré manoukian vous
invite à un voyage musical c'est à
l'espace albert camus à maurepas de la
musique aussi avec du jazz cubain
roberto fonseca sera la patrie de
guyancourt le samedi 16 novembre et puis
du théâtre musical vous attend le 17
novembre à la ferme du manet à montigny
le bretonneux
en voici un avant goût de cette
sélection moi je gagne de l'argent
l'ag qu'à attendre
c'est mon travail c'est pas ma passion
et non madame ma passion ma vraie
passion rien à voir c'est les fringues
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
je vais
voilà c'est la fin de ce set cette
culture merci de l'avoir suivi émission
que vous pouvez d'ailleurs retrouver sur
notre site internet tv soixante dix huit
points comme on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour une nouvelle
émission
[Musique]